oh damn okay stepen A Smith know where
he was last know he was last year who he
play for what the hell is he Detroit now
uh let's
see I was thinking of
Wiz for one for one like shq got the
free throw L than Chuck they are they
are Chuck help me Chuck help me oh don't
you're asking for the wrong guy no this
is tougher Charlotte harness and we just
had I was going to
say he's in Texas oh come on
there three teams in Texas man houon
give me one give me one he said Houston
but it's the Dallas
Maverick Toronto wasn't that Toronto yes
he is a Toronto
Raptor Hall of ferar temp got
be to CH 19 the New Jersey Nets oh you
you missed it on opening night and you
missed it tonight too